all right don obviously we were both
extremely passionate about
metaphysics the nature of reality the
nature of being
the nature of consciousness and this
seems to be obviously
seems to be the most first principled
question that we must have children and
adults
caring about but one of the big
arguments that you propose is that
the re the reality that that is that
this
is actually
makes it so that we are tuned to not
that
fitness function we are not tuned to the
fitness function of understanding who we
are
metaphysics but we are rather tuned to
uh
getting fitness points and procreating
so you would
would you say that that is the main sort
of
uh reason why there's so few people that
are studying
metaphysics nature of consciousness this
type of stuff
right so so yeah what i'm up to is
what we do in science all the time right
is we take our best current theories
and we push them we try to find out what
they entail
and we try to find surprising
implications of the theories and we try
to break them and that's the goal is to
push our theories to the limits try to
break them and and then we learn
something and then we try to go to the
next theory and so
that's what i'm doing with the theory of
evolution but natural selection i'm
really
just saying you know whether or not the
theory itself is true right
you know i'm not claiming that the
theory of evolution of natural selection
is true
it's the best tool we have so far it's
an incredibly powerful tool
we have nothing better so that's what
i've got to study and so the question is
does according to that tool according to
evolution about natural selection
would we be shaped to see objective
reality whatever that objective reality
might be
and um most people would think
intuitively of course we
you know you know it makes you more fit
if you see the truth right if you
mean surely someone who sees reality as
it is is going to be more fit
and have more kids than someone who
doesn't but you know those intuitions
are strong but the math of the theory of
evolution of natural selection is very
very clear
the probability of zero that any of our
senses
not just for humans but for any creature
will ever be shaped to see any aspect of
the structure
of reality whatever reality might be so
it's
it's it's again i want to make sure it's
clear that this is from
from a scientist's point of view it's
not like i'm saying evolution is true
and you know deal with it i'm saying no
this is just i mean this is our best
theory so far
and we may come up with a better theory
but here's what our current theories say
and it's a surprise uh and and it's a
mathematical theorem
so if we don't like it we may need to
try to adjust the theory of evolution
with natural selection
or we may have to live with it and say
well no this is the way it is
this is very profoundly important
because when we look around
ourselves at the world at large we don't
see
people obsessively compulsively studying
truth and wanting to understand the
nature of reality
and a lot of the time we think that oh
well that's maybe based on the
economics and the incentive systems that
make it for people
to just funnel in as cogs into like an
economic machine
um and there's been lots of
philosophical conversations around the
de
sacralization and the and the there's
not as much divinity not as much a
little bit more
nihilism maybe uh given today's
uh entrance into the a.i age and so
this is extremely extremely important
that
children born to the world adults today
are wondering
what is what is consciousness what is
this awareness
do we share this conscious awareness how
do i study this word that's infinity how
do i study
this word that is eternity what is a
theory of everything what does that even
mean why should we care about it
so part of it seems to be yes some
economical incentive
structures need to be pointed towards
that direction
for people to study truth rather than
just uh the procreation
and getting points um for in that sense
but also there's some overlap there that
that
um that we'll talk about in a little bit
would would you say that you know that
you've used this analogy so many times
and it that's just because it's so
salient and it's so relevant and
young people today that are especially
um millennials gen z and generation
alpha for sure
understand this more than the older
generations do
but the idea that that we ourselves
are as a as a desktop user interface or
as a
as a virtual reality uh headset
that we ourselves when we use these
objects like this glass of water i know
that i
sip from the glass of water and it gets
me the fitness points in terms of
not dehydrating and continuing to live
so that i can procreate
um now now that object has a higher
weight
than does the object of me reading about
sri aurobindo and the mother mural fossa
and their understandings of metaphysics
and so so the idea is that this is an
icon
in my in my on my on my user interface
on my multimodal user interface it's an
icon
but underlying this icon at the very
depths
which we're which we'll get into here in
a moment there is some sort of a
there is some sort of a source code of
that object i don't manipulate the
mathematics the voltages the transistors
etc i don't manipulate those things just
like when you play grand theft auto
or world of warcraft or minecraft you
yourself
don't go in and you don't when you drive
a car you're not manipulating the codes
that do the left all you do is you turn
left in the car
so that sort of these theories around
desktop
interfaces these theories around virtual
reality headsets
um it's interesting because they're what
is kind of the cutting edge
technologies that exist today but also
they are in a sense the most relevant
ways
of of conceptualizing this theory
and i think you did a really good job at
putting them together
in order to get this interface theory of
perception in order to get this
conscious agent theory but that's this
general idea is that there is some sort
of uh
of us of an abstract mathematical source
codes that are occurring
that are then creating some sort of a
holographic space time
uh for us to then be conscious agents
inside of that then we interact with
uh the user interface of objects for the
fitness points of procreation is that
approximately correct
right so so that's right the theory of
evolution of natural selection
entails that our senses have been shaped
not to show us the truth
whatever the truth might be and by the
way
to prove the theorem we didn't have to
actually assume we knew the truth
we could prove it without knowing what
the truth is which is very very
interesting that mathis
allows us to do that but it and so it
the theory of evolution with natural
selection clearly entails that
um using the kind of metaphors you were
talking about
it's not like our perceptions were
shaped to be a window on the truth
they're more likely to be shaped
as a user interface like a game
interface to a computer where
if you're as you say as you're playing
grand theft auto
you might have no idea that there are
voltages and magnetic fields and
insides of trillions of of you know
silicon you know transistors and so
forth
in a computer you would have no idea
that that's what you're really playing
with
and as you said um from an evolutionary
point of view
there's um very little constraint
on from natural selection for us to
want to understand ourselves at this
deeper level right it's in some sense
if you've been trained to play a game um
you might not
be inquisitive about who wrote the game
and so you
know if you ask most kids who are
playing games who wrote it that was like
i don't care what oh do you know about
the voltages and magnetic fields so who
gives a rep i mean
i just want to play the game and so you
can there is
some notion from evolution that might
point in a different direction and that
is that
that our species from an evolutionary
point of view is
a bit unusual in that um
many species occupy a small number of
niches very maybe very specific niches
and they have a limited set of fixed
strategies that only work in in certain
small niches and
we've evolved a frontal lobe
that has the ability to make models
and we can play with these models of our
environment
and see what would happen in various
circumstances
and see if we would be injured so we
could die in our model
as opposed to dying in person in in the
environment and so
one could imagine how that kind of
capacity which was originally evolved to
model
our environment and how it's hurting us
or helping us
that we could then all of a sudden sort
of co-op that to reflect on other things
right we're model builders
and all of a sudden we start to wonder
and and part of the thing is
there's a sense in which we want our
models to be right
because if our models aren't right they
won't protect us right so there is
again going to be this built-in
wish that for us to have good models and
so one could
go and interact in that direction and
try to come up with an evolutionary
story about how our species might be
sort of selected to want to have some
kind of notion of truth that sort of
maybe
builds on this model building thing
which wasn't about truth it was about
staying alive
but there was a sense of truth of the
model in the sense that it's
it's the true way to play the game right
so there's this true
i mean if i'm playing grand theft auto i
would like to know that if i turn the
wheel left
my car is not going to go to the right i
mean that's that's a true model within
grand theft auto it's not true in terms
of the diodes and resistors and the
voltages
but it's true within the context of the
game and so one could
try to tell craft a story like that
where evolution sort of shaped us to be
model builders in the game and we wanted
our model of the game to be accurate and
that then extended to
a few people more philosophically going
whoa
um could this just be a game and could i
try i mean to to get a model of it so so
i'm not saying that that's a true story
but i'm saying it's
it's an interesting way that we could
try to go within the evolutionary
theory but i do want to say that the the
next step that i've taken about
conscious agents is entirely independent
nothing about conscious agents is
dictated by the theory of evolution by
natural selection
all i'm doing there is i'm saying
evolution
by natural selection is telling us that
there's a reality
that's different from space and time and
physical objects
it's utterly different from it and
so as a scientist i'm trying to think
okay well okay
so it's not space and time and physical
objects what is it
and since i'm interested in
consciousness and what's called the hard
problem of consciousness how our
conscious experiences
like the taste of chocolate and the
smell of garlic related to brain
activity
and i'm trying to solve that problem
that's why i sort of said okay
let me propose that consciousness is the
fundamental reality
and as a scientist i need to give a
mathematically precise definition of
what i mean by consciousness and so
it ended up being as i studied it with
my wonderful colleagues jayton prakash
and
manish singh and chris fields and and
others
who work with me it's not by any means
by myself alone
um that we came up with sort of this
network model
of it's like a vast social network of
conscious agents but that's a separate
hypothesis
one could buy the argument from
evolution of natural selection that we
don't see the truth
and then say but i don't like your
theory about conscious agents i'm going
to
something else for the reality so that's
perfect or you could say i don't like
any of them but then
to look at the theory of evolution of
natural selection and
and and figure out what you think is
wrong with my theorem yeah
i'm glad that you're bringing up
the sort of
whatever we end up hypothesizing
as an ultimate reality that is beyond
what seems to be just a a user interface
that whatever we hypothesize as that it
must unfold
a quantum field theory a space time and
an evolution by natural selection
so that's really some key is that
whoever
is trying to conceptualize whatever it
may be at the most abstract mathematical
level happening it has to unfold um
those three keys but it also
it also has to uh unfold
um the conscious agent's
experience that
has a a combinatorial essence
to it that um that i interact
with the cup i drink the water that's a
very very common
experience amongst conscious agents is
drinking water
it's a lot less of a common experience
among conscious agents to have a rube
goldberg
book or music or company idea
and execute that into the world so there
are these rarities
and then there are these more
commonalities i want to i want to ask
you
about um would it would it be fair to
also
kind of call this like in a
you know is this is source code an okay
word for it is implicat like david
bowman would say is that an okay
word for it are these okay
interchangeable sorts of
yeah as long as we recognize they're
just metaphors i mean
the the real point of the theorem for
natural selection is that
there is a reality whose structure is
utterly
unlike any structure of our perceptions
almost surely
and so so so we can use various
metaphors
and you know source code is a great one
if i'm thinking about it as a user
interface absolutely
david baum's i mean a brilliant
brilliant quantum theorist um his
implicat order
trying to think out of the box um there
but as you as you pointed out
um whatever we put
in that deeper realm whether it's source
code or implicated order or in my case
a network of conscious agents um
if we're going to do science we can't
just wave our hands
we have to have a mathematically precise
statement in my case of conscious agent
networks and as you
pointed out then um there have to be
testable predictions that in principle
could disconfirm
um what i'm proposing and so
there's a some several things that that
any
real scientist would require of of my
theory
they would require that you know at some
point before we can really take it
seriously
you better show how space time emerges
and when you show a space term emerges
you better get the sciences that we have
with space time you know
general relativity special relativity
quantum field theory or
generalizations of those theories but
but but you can't do worse
you can't do worse than those stories
you got to do those areas were better
and also evolution by natural selection
and so
so this is not uh just well i think it's
consciousness and wave our hands and so
forth
we have some hard work ahead to to
for example make specific predictions
about how
the dynamics of conscious agents can
tell us
precisely the say that the amplitudes
for scattering events at the large
hadron collider
but we we have to be able to do that
kind of of concrete prediction
eventually i mean i can't do it right
right now i my team were working on it
but
but i absolutely accept that until we
have that kind of
prediction testable prediction we're not
there yet